هي الكتابه ايضا تسعى الى تخليد الى تخليد
نفسه وتخليد من يعني من حيث لا ندري من
يكتب فيها والله انا شخصيا لا لا اؤمن
بهذه النظريه النظريه
يعني يكفي يكفي يعني حتى نكسر غرور الشاعر
او غرور الروائي يكفي ان ادخله الى مكتبه
كبيره
ونساله كيف سيجد له مكانا بين كل هؤلاء
الكبار الذين
في الشعر وفي الروايه وفي غيرها من من
اجلس الادبيه
لا اظن ان هناك حاجات اولا ذاتيه
تدفعنا للكتابه
وهناك ايضا مشترك
يجعلنا نحاول الاجابه على بعض الاسئله
بالكتابه بالادب
والادب
بهذا المعنى من الممكن ان ان يكون وسيله
لفهم العالم
ولفهم التبدلات التي تطرا عليه وفي نفس
الوقت ينتج
جمالا خاصا
ونحن لا يمكن ان نقول لا داعي لان ننتج
هذا الجمال في لغتنا العربيه وفي بلدنا
المغرب فقد فهناك جمال انتجه الالمان
الفرنسيون
كل
حضاره وكل لغه
يفترض ان تنتج جمالها الخاص
وخيالها المشترك وذاكره المشتركه وفي هذا
الاطار نحن نساهم
كلنا على قدره امكانته في تحقيق هذا
المبتغى من
وجود ادب في لغه ما